hoy vamos a hablar con javier solana
básicamente este hombre se ha pasado la
política en nivel difícil todas las
pantallas una tras otra ha sido atentos
secretario general de la otan alto
representante de la unión europea para
política internacional y ministro del
gobierno de españa en otras palabras que
lo ha sido todo en esta vida y diréis
pero bueno y fonseca a ver dónde te has
encontrado tu con javier solana y dónde
estás porque obviamente esto no es mi
casa esto no es el salón de mi casa
donde me solís ver pues efectivamente
estoy en la conferencia de seguridad de
múnich que esto es pues como la gala de
los oscar pero en política es más si
vais al canal en inglés ya sabéis a
visual politiken
tenemos una entrevista con el actual
secretario general de la otan
jens stoltenberg y no sólo eso en el
canal george m sí que le encontrareis
ahí en la descripción tengo muchísimas
más entrevistas que he hecho a gente
súper interesante es más no solamente
estoy yo no sólo vais a ver mi cara
no es que a mi lado está el señor lido y
mata está y la señorita
la voy a presentar a la red
esta esta esta señorita también a na
kasparian que está en américa es en eeuu
es ua en youtuber de la leche tiene un
canal que se llama de jump works bueno
pues ella está haciendo entrevistas
también con conmigo en el canal george m
si podéis encontrar el link en la
descripción pero vamos a volver ahora ya
no te necesitamos vamos a volver vamos a
volver al tema que nos ocupa porque de
qué vamos a hablar con javier solana
pues atentos porque javier solana estado
hace unas poquitas horas reuniéndose con
la delegación de irán aquí en la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich así
que vamos a hablar de que han estado
hablando y no sólo eso cuál es el papel
de la unión europea en política
internacional realmente tiene europa una
voz o se dedica a seguir a eeuu y sobre
todo de que ha estado hablando javier
solana con los iraníes hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes no no vamos a ver un poco de
historia porque vamos a hablar con
javier solo
vamos con ellos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
señor solana muchísimas gracias por
aceptar la entrevista y por estar aquí y
hacer un hueco para que la entrevistamos
un placer
lo ha sido todo en política así la
política fue un videojuego podríamos
decir que se ha pasado todas las
pantallas como de difícil es retirarse
de la política activa
pues retirarse de la política activa yo
no me he retirado de la política sigo
haciendo política en otros foros y de
otra manera y dedicada a otras otras ser
parcelas de la vida política de la vida
colectiva que no se manifiestan en el
parlamento y no se manifiestan en las
elecciones pero yo continúo sintiéndome
un ciudadano comprometido con mi país y
por lo tanto me parece que hacer
política es lo que es la obligación de
cualquier ciudadano que es quiere su
país sí que quiere cambiar su país claro
pero bueno no estoy en activo quiere
decir que no tengo poder quiero quiero
decir que en españa tenemos el ejemplo
de josé maría aznar felipe gonzález que
como que parece que les cuesta dejar la
la política tiene un poder no tengo
poder alguno y trato de no de hacer las
cosas con la discreción que hay que
hacerlas lo trató de no trato de hacer
titulares o mis entrevistas sino trato
más de que las cosas que a mí me
produzcan que se hagan
yo no tengo el poder pero puedo tener la
influencia o la capacidad de ayudar y
catalizar si alguna cosa sea
precisamente de eso quería quería hablar
porque ahora mismo ha estado con la
delegación bueno ahora mismo hace unos
días aquí en la conferencia de seguridad
de múnich ha estado con la delegación de
irán y me gustaría saber de qué han
hablado no se olvide que yo empecé la
negociación con irán
muchos años antes de que se acabara y
estuve muchos años dedicado a esa de
negociación y tengo unas relaciones
personales bastante profundas con muchos
de ellos con el ministro de asuntos
exteriores que estuvo aquí ayer bulls de
él fue ministra de asuntos exteriores
cuando se asumió a presidente el
presidente rohan y que es el presidente
que está ahora pero yo conocía pero si
él te roja ni cuando era nacelles en la
sector nacional de con el presidente
anterior decir yo empecé yo empecé la
negociación con los iraníes en el año
2014 2015
así que fíjese en un tiempo que pasó en
que se terminara la negociación pero
mantengo una como he dicho antes una
relación muy estrecha y quiero que el
acuerdo al que se llegó no muera el
acuerdo se refiere al acuerdo de obama
el acuerdo que era cuando que es que
sigue cerró en la presidencia del
presidente obama así me parece un
disparate monumental lo que ha hecho el
presidente de trump de salirse de ese
acuerdo pero
me entiendo que la intención puede ser
buena pero eso ya está muerto quiere
decir gran salido irán ya anunciado que
vamos a ver vamos a ver abandona también
la cuerda vamos a ver yo creo que
todavía no se ha hecho por parte de irán
no ha roto ninguno de los compromisos
que tenía
se está poniendo en el límite del
acuerdo pero no ha pasado ninguna de las
líneas básicas del acuerdo por lo tanto
todavía es posible cualquier enfermo ni
citaciones básicas empezar a enriquecer
uranio
hasta un cierto nivel si a partir de un
cierto nivel pero por ejemplo hay muchas
cosas ahora se puede ahora se puede
hablar se pueden negociar con ellos que
podrían también servir para que los
americanos fueran más flexibles en su
posición los temas de misiles por
ejemplo y algún otro tema más que yo
creo que con un poco de inteligencia se
podría poner sobre la mesa y ahora estos
días ha estado hablando con el ministro
de asuntos exteriores iraní en segundo
convencerle porque yo no tengo capacidad
mismas propuestas mis sugerencias no son
sugerencias de nadie más que de una
persona que se llama javier solana sin
las cuales un amigo y un bueno una
persona que conoce muy bien el tema
porque está a muchos años comprometido
con él y que me gustaría si fuera
posible moza ayudar
pero le pregunté pero después de haber
estado estos días en la conferencia me
gustaría ver si nos pudiera explicar un
poco cómo son este tipo de reuniones es
decir tú lees las normas es también una
vida una habitación una de las dos del
hotel con un café
una persona que era yo espero nada una
norma haga una reunión corriente de
normal de dos amigos que se ven y que se
tratan de ayudar
a mí no me tiene que ayudar en nada
porque no pido nada pero yo a él sí creo
que le puedo ayudar y me gustaría
hacerlo y podemos esperarnos ahora en
2020 un ataque guerra asimétrica por
parte de irán algo como lo que vimos con
los petroleros en el estrecho de ormuz
el año pasado ella y en la zona de
tensión porque las sanciones siguen
operando sobre irán
y habrá siempre tensión mientras ese
tema no se resuelva pero en los últimos
semanas más clásicas y ya más de un mes
la situación está un poquito más calmada
no sé qué va a pasar durante la campaña
electoral presidencial eeuu cuando se
abra y no sé qué pasará con el próximo
presidente de los eeuu eso es una gran
cuestión que nuestra no sabemos lo que
va a pasar y que puede hacer europa a la
unión europea que puede hacer
yo estoy trabajando mis ideas no están
muy lejanas de las ideas de europa pero
al fin y al cabo ha sido en estos años
encargada de esa responsabilidad pero sí
creo que puede hacer alguna cosa no
mucha por un por un tema muy difícil que
los americanos están extrapolando más
allá de lo que es la interna de la ley
internacional que es las sanciones
las sanciones que se han levantado y que
se han vuelto a poner después de que se
levantaron cuando se un acuerdo y que
algunas se han vuelto a poner en esas
sanciones son sanciones americanas no
son sanciones de todos él es que eeuu
pone sanciones que al final nos tienen
que cumplir todos porque las
transacciones en para por ejemplo ayudar
el petróleo tiene que hacerse en dólares
y si los americanos no te dan los
dólares o te cambia tu dinero por
dólares pues no puedes hacer nada y en
esa situación es la que estamos ahora
pero estamos inventando algunos
mecanismos para que se pueda ayudar un
poco más aire ahí ahí es donde quería
preguntarle porque recuerdo como yo
empecé a interesarme por la política que
era la época en la que usted era el alto
representante de política internacional
en política exterior en europa
y en aquel momento es cuando bush saco
la guerra de irak y muchos países
europeos no unirnos se unieron a la
política de eeuu euro para como más
independiente de washington sin embargo
ahora con las sanciones de trampa irán
lo que estoy viendo y creo que estamos
viendo en general todos es como si
europa dice que no que no las va a
seguir pero al final
no les queda otro remedio que seguir
estados unidos de verdad europa tiene su
propia voz
tiene su propia voz lo que pasa es que
no es no es la única voz
y no tenemos la fuerza de la voz o la
potencia de la voz que tiene la primera
potencia mundial pero sí que tiene voz y
tiene no solamente voz sino tiene
voluntad de acceder de acción sí pero a
la hora de la verdad todas las empresas
europeas han tenido que retirar sus
inversiones de irán renault reseñado ya
le explica por qué porque hay unas
sanciones y esas sanciones a los
empresarios no les interesan le
sancionen a ellos
europa o sea en el terreno de los hechos
que está haciendo europa distintos
estados unidos cumplimos muchas cosas no
ponemos sanciones para empezar y estamos
tratando de no tenemos acciones pero no
compramos petróleo irán nosotros nunca
hemos comprado petróleo y gas esa europa
no es compramos nada irán lema decimos
mira el problema no es el comprar
petróleo por parte de europa un problema
es que no poder convertir petrolera
china oa india que tiene irán que
podríamos hacer alguna posibilidad de
ayudarles en eso para eso es muy
complejo muy complejo para explicarlo en
estos minutos pero sí es verdad que eeuu
quiere una responsabilidad entre
comillas responsabilidad que va más allá
de las que pueden puede tener de acuerdo
con la ley internacional esos mecanismos
por ejemplo para sustituir el modelo
swift de transacciones que proponían
europea pero ese ser no están
funcionando en el uso y funciona muy
bien lo que no lo que no funciona es lo
que no se puede cambiar cambiar el
modelo swift que es quiso con mucha
dificultad
no es fácil cambiarlo para un solo país
tampoco es fácil bueno el tema de la
conferencia en la que estamos es western
es que creo que podríamos traducir algo
así como de su occidente o un mundo sin
occidente más o menos por hacer una
traducción al español hace 20 años
parecía muy fácil definir lo que lo que
era occidente pero hoy en día
como que no está tan claro ese es el
gran debate que estamos teniendo que eso
que hemos vivido
dos cosas en el año 2016 2017 muy
importantes desde el punto de vista de
romper con el multilateralismo las
elecciones de bus las elecciones
de trump significan un cambio
fundamental en la visión que europa
tiene del mundo europa tiene del mundo
del mundo de la globalización una idea
de que de los grandes problemas globales
solo tienen resultados o sólo pueden
tener soluciones globales por lo tanto
se necesita instituciones globales es
decir multilateralismo mientras que el
presidente también niega todo eso dice
que los problemas se deben resolver
bilateralmente y no cree en el
multilateralismo por lo tanto estamos
ahora mismo en dos posiciones
completamente opuestas y podemos
encontrar alguna fórmula de encuentro
por ser lo mejor pero en este momento
estamos con dos concepciones del mundo
de los países de dos grandes potencias
europeas o por una ley a mercados
centrales europa
y llegados bros en un tema fundamental
estamos en desacuerdo ya pero qué pasa
hemos hablado de eeuu las relaciones
entre eeuu y europa pero qué pasa con
modelos alternativos porque donde queda
oxidante cuando en muchos países sobre
todo en áfrica parece que empiezan a
mirar a china como un modelo a seguir
como un modelo un ejemplo de país en
desarrollo y desde país pobre que está
dejando de serlo con una modelo
totalmente distinto africano es no forma
parte de occidente no no forma parte de
los modelos occidentales claro pero
occidente en un modelo antes y ahora hay
otros
por lo visto yo no sé si te si el modelo
de los de china puede ser un modelo
aplicable para áfrica yo creo que no
pero pueden estar mirando otros modelos
de democracia y liberal democracia que
no es la democracia liberal que nosotros
defendemos sino mecanismos que están que
del medio entre la democracia
el autoritarismo y esto es lo que está
subiendo quizá en el mundo los países
con regímenes autoritarios que
formalmente son democracias porque votan
pero el cumplimiento de la ley que es lo
fundamental de una democracia no sé no
existe el del respecto a la ley en
algunos casos es que directamente por
kagamé por ejemplo el presidente de
ruanda ahora es común él dice el mismo
que su modelo es singapur que la
democracia tiene poco él no tiene ningún
problema en reconocer que es un líder
autoritario y sin embargo es un modelo
también para los africanos bueno que
hagan es un modelo para los africanos
para muros americanas bueno bueno es un
modelo por lo salvar los americanos en
más que en la política en los resultados
económicos que kagamé han tenido unos
resultados económicos bastante buenos y
pasó por unas tramas terribles que sacó
sobre un genocidio
que hubo sobre su país es un gran líder
qué bueno qué
que se ha pasado de rosca digamos pero
fue un gran líder en un momento dado y
luego pues ha seguido siendo un régimen
autoritario la gente le vota pero el
rule of law no se cumple y eso no es un
desafío para los valores occidentales
los que sea que éstos sean porque son
fundamentales o son fáciles de decir
muchos reyes no se cumplen sobre todo el
respeto a la ley no respeta la ley es
fundamental de o creo que la democracia
no solamente es votar si no la
democracia tiene como elemento
fundamental el respeto a la ley la
separación de poderes es decir que la
justicia esté separada de el ejecutivo y
que la libertad de prensa y de expresión
este también separada del gobierno bueno
antes de terminar me gustaría hacerle
unas preguntas finales lo que llamamos
rapid fire questions cuando hacemos las
entrevistas en inglés
en pocas palabras cuál es el principal
tema de discusión con sus hijos o con
sus nietos en el caso de que los tengan
los hijos y tengo nietos cuál es su
principal tema de discusión de discusión
pues algunos es la hora de irse a
acostar cuando están viviendo en mi casa
y cuánto tiempo pueden ver la televisión
o no políticamente tienen algún drama
son muy pequeños todavía y con sus hijos
mis hijos son mis hijos mis hijos de más
o menos tenemos unas ideas parecidas no
tengo grandes grandes debates políticos
pero si seguimos muy de cerca
conjuntamente la política no sólo la
española si la política internacional
nunca he salido único euroescéptica
bueno dijo que puede estar mi hijo por
ejemplo está menos comprometido con la
vida podría que yo está a unos niveles
no todo el mundo puede ser javier solana
bueno por favor complete esta frase con
una palabra
ser político significa
ser honrado
en una palabra que característica falta
en nuestra sociedad
la solidaridad
muchísimas gracias por sus respuestas de
verdad muchísimas gracias ha sido un
placer hacer una entrevista
entrevista muy muy muy dinámicamente
bueno lo intento por lo menos
[Música]